ils ont opéré sans relâche depuis hier
soir soigner des blessures par balles
mais surtout des blessures faites à la
machette et à la che des mutilations aux
pieds à la tête par tous évacués hier
soir sur la base arrière de l'opération
turquoise ici à goma au zaïre
ces blessés tous de l'ethnie tutsie
viennent de la région sud du rwanda où
ils s'étaient réfugiés pour fuir les
massacres c'est une patrouille française
qui les a trouvés caché dans la montagne
espérant ne plus rencontrer l'armée et
les milices de l'autre etc ni qui les
poursuit lui ces jours et qui n'hésite
pas à mettre à mort les enfants les
soldats et les dvd est saisi et
et marche des beurs des bains à remous
des épées et des armes traditionnelles
wingles et des armées modernes même
contre les enfants
même contre les enfants tutsi
oui même les enfants sont même henin
fera deux jours on qui vous a tiré
dessus
c
d'allouagne
l'armée gouvernementale pourquoi parce
que vous êtes tout y est
dans l'après midi devraient suivre ici à
goma une deuxième vague d'évacuation de
blessés tous si des rescapés des
massacres que l'armée recherchait depuis
une semaine
eux et tous ceux qui n'osent pas encore
sortir de leur cachette
terré quelque part dans les forêts du
rwanda